the current experiment I'm involved with
is called xenon 110
- Mentos experiment located under the
mountains of the Gran Sasso in central
Italy where we have the largest
underground laboratory worldwide we are
searching for the dark matter which
fills this universe 85% of the matter in
the universe is invisible it's dark
and despite the efforts about decades we
still don't know the nature of that
mental so we have many hypotheses many
candidates the most favorite one remains
today the wing the weakly interacting
massive particle and so we are searching
for wimps in liquid xenon with the Zeno
Anton experiment waiting for an
interactional is particle with an atom
and nucleus of the xenon which is inside
our beautiful detector and capitalizing
on the properties of this liquid xenon
to detect these signals very precisely
so the experiment is the largest so far
until now and the most sensitive for
direct detection of that meant it just
started to operate a green salsa at the
laboratory and we are very excited to to
discover wimps in the cuisine and widows
in Owenton experiment